and global citizen announced this
morning it will bring its festival to
South Africa for the very first time
they had a big announcement there this
morning John Legend has performed at the
festival he's a longtime supporter joins
us bright and early from Los Angeles
John we so appreciate that but this is
such a big big deal to go to South
Africa for the very first time
partnering with the house of Mandela and
the global citizen seems like a perfect
partnership we need Mandela's words and
legacy more than ever yes we do and
we're celebrating Mandela's 100th
birthday this year and so we wanted to
throw a concert in South Africa to
celebrate that and to focus on the goal
of ending extreme poverty and we believe
we can do it and we've made a lot of
progress a lot of organizations over the
years have been working toward this goal
and global citizen is mobilizing folks
and mobilizing resources so that we can
really focus on this goal of ending
extreme poverty and what better way to
do that then celebrating Mandela's
birthday in South Africa I thought about
what Mandela said in 2005 overcoming
poverty is not a gesture of charity it
is an act of justice it is the
protection of a fundamental human right
the right to dignity and a decent life
how do these concerts move towards
helping to end poverty well we focus a
lot of people's energy and attention on
this issue and we raise a lot of money
the concerts and themselves aren't
necessarily doing all the money raising
but I believe the attention that's
brought to the issue through the
concerts is really a big part of
mobilizing money and this year we're
trying to mobilize a billion dollars
toward this goal and then John what's
the message to the concert goers I mean
other than just the wonderful and
beautiful music about being active in
this global effort it's it's really
highlighting the idea that we really are
global citizens that we're all in this
together that we should look at human
beings who live across the world as our
neighbors as our brothers and sisters
and that we should do what we can to
come together in extreme poverty and
make life more livable for people all
around the world this is what's so great
about you John Legend because you've
been with global citizen from the very
beginning have been very active from the
very very first concert no I remember
and as a little kid I was reading Nancy
Drew books as a little kid you were
reading books about social justice and
how to make this world a better place
what what made you gravitate toward that
subject in particular at a very young
age I was always inspired by dr. King I
was inspired by Gandhi other people that
sacrifice themselves to make the world
better for other people
those are my heroes when I was a kid and
I also wanted to be a musician but I
always believed that if I were going to
be a successful musician that I was
going to use my platform to try to make
the world better for other people John
talked a little bit about the evolution
of social change in music ain't gonna
play Sun City was used to promote the
idea of apartheid in South Africa and
change minds about that now you're going
bounce it back to South Africa an
amazing journey just there and social
justice and music talk a little bit
about how that's evolved well I think
musicians and artists have always had a
role in speaking truth to power telling
the truth as we see it mobilizing people
inspiring people bringing people
together and I think we should continue
that role as artists continue to try to
make a difference and as we entertain as
we bring people together preach a
message of love and unity over division
and hate John last time we did an
interview with you it was just baby Luna
and I'll never forget the Luna song
somebody's so now you have a little baby
boy Myles you must have a mild song
already because you're John Legend well
he gets the diaper song too all you have
to do is change the name and what's it
like now having two little ones in the
household we love it we're having so
much fun with both of them Luna is
really a great big sister she's been so
loving toward Milo's and likes to take
care of him with us and it just feels
good to have our little family growing
together yeah she's not looking at him
like how long is he gonna stay
you know everyone said she was going to
do that but she's been really good with
him and you can tell there are moments
when she gets a little jealous of the
attention even when she's jealous she
kind of acts out in a good way she'll
like do something you know to get our
attention but it's usually not
necessarily a bad thing it's it's
usually like more singing and more
dances so I'm like okay there's a legend
I know Tegan household so looking
forward to meeting Myles seeing you in
South Africa thanks a lot we knew you
were great with the piano keys but
you're also good at the burping well
done dad well thank you so much for
joining us appreciate it thank you